you know every other day is is seven
eight homicides just right here from a
one or two block radius
and and everybody really just fooled
they fooled about
the truth is this
we fought we got through it people died
we lost lives
but at the same time we have to come to
a common ground i said love is enough
[Music]
wow out of all the days that i've been
on the roof i must say i am really
really excited today to talk with you
about some rooftop revelations
i am corey brooks and i'm still here on
this rooftop living in this tent for 100
days from november 20th to february 28th
bringing about awareness to gun violence
in chicago but most of all to build a
center on the south side of chicago on a
block that we call old block named after
a young man who was shot and killed
named od perry
we took the o and we're going to keep it
we're just going to flip it and make it
into opportunity opportunity block
i'm excited today because i have two of
the guys
who were
notorious in our neighborhood
for
gang banging
drugs
all the kind of stuff
that we've been trying to change
and i'm glad because
they're not only here today
but they're reformed they've changed
their lives and they both work for our
organization project hood can you
believe that so i want to introduce
to all of my fox family and all of those
who are watching and listening i want to
introduce to you
dale that we call a big deal you can see
he getting smaller now though he was
bigger he was a lot bigger this is big
deal and this is twin and uh his real
name is barney and uh these guys if you
can believe it
were arch enemies they were on two
different sides he was a gd
gangsta disciple he was a bd a black
disciple and they all
both lived in the same neighborhood
but it was
conflict
so i'm gonna let them tell a story and
we're gonna talk about
how the conflict has been resolved how
lives have been changed and years later
now they're doing something to change
our neighborhood so welcome guys
absolutely absolutely so
then i'ma start with you take us back a
little bit uh to where you all used to
feud and what how that came about what
did you all used to be
doing in the neighborhood oh man besides
tearing up everything
well you know we uh we told the
neighborhood up
seriously throw it up
uh
it was a different uh different
demographic
a different day
we mainly thought about money
you may fall about real estate you know
killing and fighting was uh it was
different back then
because it was a it was a purpose to us
we looked at things different like nah
so many kids down from my new problems
uh
man man twin we you know we we can see
each other on any given day
and if he in the wrong spot or in the
wrong place
it's getting it's we're going to get to
it right then to drop it back
so it was like it was it was kind of
like mapped off
it was what it was that we was what we
would say
but if we ever bumped up it was serious
business
real serious business and the thing that
uh
back then there wasn't no social media
so a lot of things didn't get uh
publicized publicized as it do these
days
but twin
we weren't that cool back then
let me hear what you got to say you know
i hear dale talk about how y'all weren't
that cool back then but take us back
from your perspective how it used to be
in the neighborhood and and also how far
away from y'all how far like how many
blocks because i don't think people
really understand how close these blocks
are that are in conflict
oh well we was one block radius i mean
one block one block when he was on
calumet it was on prairie
um we was on 60 61st 61st
and kate davis on 60 first and forever
but i mean you gotta understand back in
our days
even though we uh we had conflict uh we
had violence taking place
we had structure let's not skip that
part we had structure meaning
let's not take away from dale he was the
girl
i mean girl meaning he was a big boss he
called it for the neighborhood so
everything that take place it had to go
through his accord it had to come off
his account if he said if he's saying
that happened it happened right what i'm
saying and it was the same thing on my
end vice versa i had the spot the
minister spot co-minister sparta chief
of
security when we when we uh was out
gang-banging
we were gang-banging but let's talk
about the part that we really want
people to understand when we said there
was peace
you wasn't breaking that peace treaty i
was over which i'm saying see this is
the part that i really want y'all to
understand when we said that was peace
you couldn't break that peace street if
you broke that peace treaty it was
rather it was my end or his aunt he was
going to the hospital
because that's what's the structure back
then i'm saying so that was the most
important part of us uh having this
conversation right now starting off that
i want people to understand there's no
unity there's no structure and we wasn't
considered as gang bangers either what
i'm saying we call ourselves businessman
because we was about business we just
about making some money at the end of
the day which i'm saying but despite the
all the money we made all the violence
that we participate in
it still boils down to the number one
thing we
messed up our community with it with the
activities that we brought to our
community i want y'all to understand
that much and let me just share this um
and you both didn't know what i was
going to talk about and i wanted to
bring up something because when you go
down a certain
track a certain lifestyle
you end up
bringing your kids into that lifestyle
sometimes that's it i know it was never
intended and i know it even hurts for us
to even talk about it not you know but i
want to talk about it because
i need people to understand
and and i know y'all so y'all i love
y'all y'all love me so i don't have to
pull punches
but yo your son was shot by he's in a
wheelchair my son paralyzed my son was
shot your namesake too yeah my little
barney leverny my firstborn was shot
uh somebody pulled up on him he was in a
car shot at him 30 times and he got hit
one time in the back of the paralyzed so
he's paralyzed from the chest down he's
been paralyzed for five years now
and when uh that situation took place i
was just coming home from jail
uh due to the fact that i knew my son
was out in the streets doing street
activities the city thought maybe that
it was going to be an uproar but i took
the social media something i really
don't do but i wanted the world to know
and understand that there would not be a
retaliation despite what happened to my
son because at the end of the day i know
he's in the street i know he has caused
harm on somebody else's child so there
won't be no retaliation and i just thank
god that my son you know i'm saying
their parents from this incident even
though he's paralyzed but i had to sit
him down and help him understand it's a
timeout for a lot of things what i'm
saying because we're losing a lot of
kids lives in the process of situation
absolutely and now
um you know twin son
was shot
even though he was paralyzed he lived
and he still got a chance to him in the
sun to resolve a lot of conflicts and
issues and they got a great relationship
and uh but
in your situation
just recently yeah uh your son was shot
yeah i lost monster and didn't make it
but you know it's like even even people
with twins
and uh you know it's it's so fresh for
me
with my son but
i'm glad you know we get a chance to
like shine a light on it because
a lot of these other kids need to know
to really understand like
in spite of whatever we do or whatever
we go
i could call twins on right now
when i when he answers the phone or i
facetime you see me
what's up huh and the same thing with my
son exactly so the thing is with these
kids and what they don't understand like
they fight they fight a lot and that's
what we had to grow up
and understand and it's like
so long
like seven years ago eight years ago now
while i changed my life because i
started seeing maki
grow older and i started seeing them
picking up my habits
so i had to change my life
i came to the church
bowser gave me a chance
we reformed it and we switched it
that's the reason why i'm here with 29
with pastor and we fight so hard for the
community center or
things like that do we need because
these kids don't have a they don't have
a chance but they don't have they don't
have a
a right target they gotta aim
but they aim is going back to them and
killing each other they aim is not
okay well we gonna get up and we go
we'll go to the community center and
they might have these jobs for us all
right they might have this studio for us
what they might have is they don't have
the same privileges
as
a kid maybe a hundred miles away
so it's important even 20 miles right oh
yeah exactly even 20 miles up north is
starting to be terrible so it's either
it's it's even
more of a
fight a uphill battle and a problem
because
well we fighting we really got our back
against the wall
you know every other day is is 7 8
homicides just right here from a one or
two block radius
and and everybody really just fooled
they fooled about
the truth is this
we fought we got through it people died
we lost lives
but at the same time we have to come to
a common ground and say enough is enough
how we how we wouldn't want a community
center
it's well deserved and we want our kids
to live
so why wouldn't they be supportive why
wouldn't we support them
because then you guys don't understand
like us growing up
we was misled also as kids we didn't
have a pastor in the neighborhood seven
days a week 24 hours on call like you
you i'm saying we we was raised up with
a gun in the pack you know what i'm
saying and and i'm old older guys they
misled us one of our older heads here he
worked for the church you know what i'm
saying and he said my overhead and i
respect him to this day but if we had if
i know what i know now i'll take a
different route in life you see i'm
saying you know what i want to say
something about what you just said
you know what you know right now so what
are you doing right now with the
knowledge that you have like what type
of work are you doing and
what is that all about well i mean right
now you know
thanks to you you gave me the
opportunity you gave me a chance oh
doesn't speak for but you gave me a
chance to come to the community i work
for the project hood violent prevention
team as well as my brother dale here um
we on the line every day seven days a
week you know calls come out saying
shots fired anytime those calls come out
me and the rest of my team we up they
don't mind if it's two three o'clock in
the morning we're racing to get to these
locations to try to see what's going on
how can we help to the family how can we
perfect the next situation to take place
and this is a seven day uh 24-hour job
that we right now took upon ourselves
just to be able to get back to our
community you know what i'm saying and
it's a risky job but at the end of the
day me and dale we made the decision to
say listen we need to put our life on
the line and try to get back and save
some some of these kids lives from the
things that's taking place in these
neighborhoods every day
i'ma say this
but
a lot of people sit back and speculate
and you watch the news you watch the
problems you watch the violence
and it really don't affect you to hit
your front line or hit your front door
and that's the thing that we need to
stop sitting around waiting on
we need to stop sitting around waiting
on
as far as to say a superman or
a super giant to come in and save us
us gotta save us save myself they gotta
start they gotta start as a head as a
home
so if you know your if you know your
child need help
or you know your child need attention
find him being a serial shooter or a
problem
and come come to project hill
come to the valley impact team come to
pass come sit on this roof it's open
arms
so we can get together right now and
stop the violence head on we can't keep
waiting on nobody
that's why he on this roof 100 days it's
something else just sitting on this roof
and in the cold
yeah eating right and baby you ain't
doing this
sacrifice yeah
so when when is everybody else as a
whole gonna sacrifice
even with donating a dollar a whole lot
of fiction whatever it is every penny
count let's help let's help build this
community center
to give our kids
a different change and a different
outlook a different target
the target shouldn't be the next human
being the target should be to change
that's what i'm here for
i mean i i changed my life
to change not just to save my kids
because i got a lot of kids just like
past that that's not my kids but like
twin is not my kid or any other people
that's with the vip team
you know i'm grieving right now my son
been gone almost
40 days
but i'm still gonna do the work because
this way he will run
you know you do the history on my
channel i don't have a bad kid my kids
ain't shot nobody ain't killed nobody
but it's just it's not it's the way of
the world guilty by association so we
got to change it if we don't do nothing
to change it it's not never gonna happen
and there's not no walk in the car this
ain't no walking apart
but if somebody get a time up
100 days
imagine that
we have to start looking at situations
and put ourselves
in the next man's shoes for the next
woman's shoes
we got a change
i think that's the perfect way to end
the show
uh the rooftop revelations
here on the south side of chicago
i love these two guys i love the changes
that they made
i love what they're trying to do
but most of all
i love that they're worried about the
whole neighborhood not just their kids
but all kids
until tomorrow
i just want to say thank you fox for
giving us this platform
and peace
you